there isn't a question quite as
universal in the history of cinema as
what makes Pixar so great in just 24
years the studio has not only introduced
an entirely new medium for storytelling
but has managed to elevate that form to
a staple of our pop culture consistently
creating generation-defining works that
have come to define what good animation
looks and feels like all of its films
are pure technological marvels but I
think it's far from what makes the films
so special these are just a great new
expensive pencils you know that's what
it says is it's artists using these
computers as though you know an artist
at Disney use a piece of paper and a
pencil because the focus of what we do
is still where it's most important and
that's where the story and the
characters Pixar's obsession with
stories is actually quite well known
none of its films is ever made just once
each painstakingly rewritten and re-edit
it until it's right it's how the version
of Toy Story 2 we all know was finished
in just 9 months when Pixar unimpressed
with its first cut decided to start from
the very beginning the story so how does
Pixar get its story right to understand
it we can take a look at its 22 rules of
storytelling each gives a unique insight
into how its writers work but five of
them are essential in understanding what
makes its films so special
[Music]
okay not what I had in mind
the first rule is in understanding the
structure of a story all Pixar movies
are generally formatted the same way
we're first introduced to the characters
and watched them in their routine life
until the safety of that routine is
shattered by an unexpected change the
rest of the film follows the characters
struggle against this change until from
the experience they reach a lesson in
this way the stories of Pixar are always
about changes in Toy Story it was the
arrival of a new toy and an inside out
they move to a new city and in up the
death of a loved one the film tells the
story of characters who are struggling
to accept or adapt to the changes around
them but in a world created by Pixar
changes are also opportunities to grow
and learn from they're just not aware of
it yet and this conflict is so clear to
us as viewers because Pixar takes its
time in helping us understand who they
are which brings us to our next rule
jority of Pixar's magic lies in its
characters and they always feel real and
complex because the writers give each of
them an opinion
the future is can only be more of this
this is the way things are now these
opinions don't necessarily have to be
agreeable or at times even likeable as
long as they're understandable and
giving characters real opinions matter
because they in time incite real
emotions and it's these emotions that
Pixar uses to breathe life into its
characters joy in inside out is
oblivious to the importance of negative
emotions woody in Toy Story grows
jealous of the attention on you toy
receives just wants things to go back to
how they were these are ideas and
emotions that are universal that anyone
can relate to kids or adults they aren't
good emotions but they are honest and
this honesty helps us to relate to them
and although Pixar has its fair share of
diabolical villains I think Pixar movies
shine the most when they lack one
Wendy's honest yet ugly emotions surface
to become the villain of the pot toy
story's villain isn't Sid but woody
whose jealousy sets off the main
conflict and an inside out none of
Riley's emotional breakdowns would have
even happened if joy had simply accepted
that other emotions could matter as much
as herself and when these characters
resist change
Pixar throws them a challenge in the
form of coins urns
Pixar has no problem using coincidences
a lot sometimes it's indirectly set off
by the characters and others well just
pure coincidences but it's how they use
them that's different
whereas bad writing uses coincidences to
get characters out of a tough situation
Pixar uses coincidences to get them into
one these coincidences put characters in
situations where they're forced to
confront and adapt to the changes but
none serves as an easy way out so the
characters who have to get themselves
out this makes the stakes higher and
every problem a bit more personal and
even an occasion where it might seem
like a deus ex machina it's a payoff and
also a chance for a great character
moment once the characters find
themselves in trouble
Pixar shifts its focus to who they're
sharing the experience
villains often make a great tool for
understanding a protagonist because
quite often they embody their polar
opposites
Pixar uses villains for the same reason
but more often than not these opposites
are introduced as supporting characters
it's no secret that Pixar movies are
heavily inspired by the buddy film genre
a genre almost as long as the history of
film itself but it's a rather perfect
John refer inspiration given what Pixar
tries to achieve through its films to
teach a lesson
most of us learn through others and
opinions that differ from our own the
same rule applies in the world of Pixar
joy learns the importance of other
negative emotions and of their symbiotic
harmony
thanks to her journey with sadness and
Carl and up is able to move on from the
death of his wife because of the journey
with a boy who resembles his younger
self but it's the opposite of the man
he's grown to be as film puts two
opposing forces through a series of
challenges the two characters have no
choice but to grow and learn from each
other
which leads us to our final point the
lesson what's he doing in there I like
to call it a Pixar moment in every film
there's a point where everything just
clicks when we along with the characters
learn what the entire experience has
been all about it's what a lot of bad
stories get wrong
they're busy force feeding us themes and
motifs that desperately scream for
attention but in the works of Pixar
everything is far more subtle in a lot
of ways Pixar tells a story just like
how we learn our lessons they're never
expected they never come easy and we
fail constantly in the process but at
the end of it all it becomes clear why
the journey was worth taking it all
feels real and organic because we learn
with these characters rather than from
them it's all really just beautiful
storytelling there's no doubt that Pixar
has a perfect handle on how to tell a
story but beyond that Pixar's greatest
strengths might lie in knowing what its
story is about it might look like an
abandoned robot a family of superheroes
toys or emotions but in the end it's
really a story about us